welcome to this video playing cow from
the US let's see a sloth let's play the
slowest love with you through yeah here
she takes d5 is a line that is some
surprisingly interesting check after
Bishop disabled as queen bee three this
is some slightly better position four ID
it looks very harmless but this some
exactly this is so a bit uncomfortable
for luck the night on b5 is some a very
annoying piece it always attacks a seven
in combination with the night on a six
this is quite tricky yeah and now it it
starts to become a concrete problem yeah
like and he can do all that the thing is
that a seven is hanging at the end so
what is going on if I can't just take it
all off yeah very technical play but at
the end a seven is gone okay
let's let's check this he's trying to to
play knight c6 here
the night on hmm yeah this is in fact in
fact much more interesting that it might
look at further look at first because my
king is actually playing and his gang is
not um interesting
yeah I probably need to take I don't
really see an alternative and now he
needs to exchange this might otherwise
suspicious business trapped and
threatening to play again and maybe he
can play one more move but then he needs
to take it I will probably take it
straight away the main issue is my king
is small act of lame placed it actually
takes part in the game his King is not
doing that once my view is playing
simple simple chess
kini ate this 97 so this is not
and now i have the d6 scram available
now go bishop II one there's always a
night see one unfortunately our wait
wait just for a moment if I go 96 what
is supposed to be what is this response
come on this is just wrong I think I
should be able to to win this shouldn't
I
so let's see b5 i can probably just kill
96cm now i have have it wrapped let's
see just know it how do i now get this
guy to lie to be three and qingyuan
when's the night yeah this is over
simply you can try to rescue the night
be three check King takes check on c1
King see 292 but you are all of his out
of squares basically i came i want to
want this important poor 95 which limit
is a king position
they go King be one he always has be
three for the Montague rescuing yes I
can't even take him check and now let's
briefly consider if I don't know it
knight c6 checking d7 king be one I'm
not 100% sure that this is a winning key
and pawn in game with Knight c3 check
yeah but it is a winning champ own again
it is a winner and this should be the
easiest way to go check
King d3i deform but I this wasn't the
easiest way to play it really wasn't
yeah it's it it's enough I think but
probably add some some easier way to
play I can always do queen a king d
three von Drago's King c5 and then the
idea is to to after yeah is it important
actually can do this first the ideas
that after he for takes King takes I
need to invite on the Kings side and
this is why i am trying to provoke him
the pawns to go to go forward so II form
takes King takes King see [ __ ] f four
kings 23 king g5 and I'm winning the
pawns check
yeah well it it it was it was easy after
all
time morning's is somewhat irritating
okay let's let's just push the poem
check what was this chat heck channel
this is aimless check Raquel Alfred
cannot blew us off game drawn like a
complete idiot or what what the heck
this is actually a mistake I completely
forgot about King d3 if fall it still
wins I can just push h4 it's over this
is promoting with a check oh man I've
got 35 seconds on the clock in this
position our king of three is such a
routine with you think you blocked the
pond and then it's going going like that
yeah this is a draw but how do actually
win here the issue is his temple gain
with e4 check lon old this is such a
such a straightforward win all along
this game and then you spoil it with
such once City move unknown may I can
still play this and end wind according
to the comp because of the check check
this and then I'm promoting with the
check check Kim comp says that this is
winning but hmm did some well i don't
think i have a straightforward queen
trade so be cautious with calling you to
win yeah how idiotic can you play I mean
this was such a straightforward win and
it was completely this was really
steak going into the key in porn again I
mean it is probably winning but I mean
this this kind of event game-winning you
sleep because he's got all the
weaknesses this was just a very bad
plane very bad play they are just very
bad i mean i shouldn't have done that
it's always tempting to go into the key
and porn and game but this is something
you you just wins completely routinely
threatening here go here pick up all the
pawns it's a complete no-brainer ah ok
thanks for watching